oh my God wait you're it's true that
you're named after like County yes
County Kerry in Ireland yes that's do
you have pretty obvious right that I
would be named after a county in Ireland
do you hail from do I answer yes family
my mom's family is Jamaican but she's
traced The Roots back to like Scottish
Irish Pirates Who landed in the
Caribbean kind of amazing that's so hot
yeah now
um La Roche
um your extraordinary image architect he
is yes yes we worked with Zendaya he
works with you you guys decided to put
on that iconic Whitney Houston dress
yeah all his idea truly I was getting
this award for excellence in the Arts
but it was from a black organization and
I thought if we're talking about black
Excellence tonight then that's the
moment to pull out the Whitney Houston
dress
well
um
so uh is it true that Whitney's not your
only style icon that also um you sported
an iconic hairdo at one point what
um and yeah we have a photo
didn't we all have the Rachel didn't we
all have the Rachel the funniest thing
is that picture's actually from we did a
production of Hamlet at school at my
high school and I was playing Ophelia so
I was playing this like classic
character from Shakespearean literature
but with the Rachel haircut like that's
what teenagers do and I didn't know this
you were a substitute teacher was what
was that life crazy so I love teaching I
love it's like it's in my blood my
mother was a teacher and I it was a
great job to have when I was auditioning
because if they needed teachers they
would call me in the morning and say
like can you come in for the day if I
had an audition I'd say no but you know
most of the time as an actor you're just
waiting for auditions so a lot of times
I would go and substitute teach and I I
loved it so much that I actually had to
instate a rule where I wouldn't go to
the same school more than three days in
a row because I would just fall in love
with the kids and I would lose sight of
my dreams you know I would be like I
don't need to act I can just devote my
life to these kids and I'd want to adopt
them and take them home and um so I
would only be at a school for three days
and then I would have to switch schools
and I actually after I did Save the Last
Dance I still I didn't make enough money
on that movie to survive so I went back
to teaching and I got in trouble because
when I would substitute teach in high
schools the kids would cut class to see
Chenille from Save the Last Dance So the
principal called me and was like you can
only do elementary schools you cannot do
high s anymore because these kids all
want to meet Chenille it's not okay
when you're like life intersects like
that so weird they were also like how's
she teaching high school isn't she in
high school I was like no
no you're a teacher you come from
teachers you know you're in a highly
intelligent person and smart and
talented and you produce and you're just
I could say all of those things about
you right all these same things
I like you so much
[Applause]
well I'm really excited because it just
got announced that you are going to
write a memoir and like it's not going
to like you're in a process yeah you're
committed final edits like they're
trying to pull pull it from me and I'm
like well I need to do more work okay
what what is that like okay I cannot
tell you how many times I actually
because I think growing up your Memoir
may have been the first Memoir I ever
read right little girl lost yes so I
read that as a teenager I think it was
my first Memoir and I have thought so
many times writing this like how did you
do that at such a young age it's so it I
feel like this is the thing that has
required the most creative courage from
me than anything else I've ever done and
I'm just in awe that you were able to
share yourself that generously so long
ago is there an area that's challenging
you and making you the most nervous or
vulnerable or tentative about writing
and if so what is it
um I don't I oh gosh it's so hard
because I'm in the midst of it but I
will say I I definitely started writing
it because I was trying to make sense of
my life I think after the years of
playing Olivia Pope I realized
um she was so important to me and she
was my everything and in some ways I
realized I've spent my life being these
other people and I think I need to spend
a little bit of time working on
understanding me that's so much of the
journey I've been on I'm going to be
happy on this every word of this book
when's it coming out in the fall Well it
can't happen soon enough
we have to go to break and then Carrie
is going to take us behind the scenes of
her most famous films and shows
[Music]